[Music]  the first difficult step is done the  negotiations between the European Union  and the British prime minister Teresa  may have led to a deal we have secured  the rights of dear citizens in UK and  vice-versa we have found an agreement  financial settlement governance  graphical indications etc we still want  the UK as an essential partner in all  fields for many years to come we are in  fact at the decisive moment in this  process no one no one should lose sight  of the process the progress that had  been achieved in Brussels and in London  this deal is fair and balanced it takes  into account the UK positions in  particular we are fond of compromise to  avoid a border between Ireland and also  9 on both sides both parties want to  avoid using the backstop these deal  allows for the orderly withdrawal which  is our common interest for the future  relationship both the UK will have full  control of their own legislation and  rulemaking